[Music]
the lead certificate programs are very
interactive very intense programa is
very collaborative as well the high
quality of content that delije program
offers and the collaborative tools and
platform provide learning and innovation
and leadership I've taken some of the
MOOC classes before on my own I've done
some various things online the lead
certificate program is a whole another
class of experience that online tools
are amazing it's extremely easy to make
your way around you can schedule your
your work as you need to the most
surprising thing about the lead
certificate program has been its amount
of diversity you have people from all
around the world from every continent
from different industries you really
learn from different backgrounds
different ideas and thoughts the lead
certificate has expanded my mind it love
leveled the way I think about
influencing and making change happen and
most importantly perhaps especially the
design thinking cause made me realize
that business is really about people all
the graphs all the spreadsheets that's
all really important but when you put
the people at the center of the business
that's when you have a chance to do
something different one of the greatest
things that I'm learning from the lead
program is the ability to take something
complicated and make it intuitive for
others that's been invaluable it's a
false relationship you have to
professors that teach the programs I
wrote numerous of them during her during
the classes they write back immediately
it's pretty amazing we all have busy
schedules we have to be able to manage
our time and I think that some of the
things that we learned through the
course are ways to do that being able to
learn new methodologies and new ways of
approaching things you can actually save
some time doing things a little more
efficiently the late certificate has
made me more intentional in the way I
make decisions on a day to day basis
[Music]